Usually when we talk about how the 2020 Democratic
primary is looking, we talk about national
polls and in national polls, Joe Biden has
and is leading followed by Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders who have sort of been trading
off second and third place.
But that's national polling and in practice,
the primaries don't happen all at once.
They don't happen all on one day.
The first caucus is February 3rd in Iowa.
The first primary is February 11th in New
Hampshire.
And so New Hampshire is a very important early
state in setting the tone of the primaries.
But at the same time, we don't want to give
New Hampshire more importance than it actually
has.
Because remember that in 2016 Bernie Sanders
handily won the New Hampshire primary over
Hillary Clinton, but ultimately was not the
Democratic nominee.
So let's look at New Hampshire in New Hampshire,
there is a new poll that is getting a lot
of attention in which Bernie Sanders has passed.
Joe Biden, the poll is from Gravis.
Biden has been leading every New Hampshire
poll dating all the way back to who even knows,
I mean a long time dating too.
Before he even announced that he was actually
running.
And now we have one new poll in which Bernie
Sanders has passed Biden, sort of Bernie Sanders
at 21 Joe Biden at 15 but the poll has a 6.2%
margin of error and only 250 primary voters
were actually asked their view on who they
will vote for in the primary.
So in reality, again, I'm just the Messenger
here, I'm just looking at what's on the screen.
In reality, even though Bernie Sanders is
leading Joe Biden by six, the pole has a 6.2%
margin of error and it is a statistical tie.
So some people are maybe making more of a
big deal out of this poll than they should.
This is one poll within the margin of error,
but the trend has been a clearly anti Biden
trend in New Hampshire.
Now, some other important caveats, I'm not
being positive or negative.
I'm not a Biden guy.
I'm a Bernie Warren Guy.
I'm just being a realist.
New Hampshire is Vermont's neighbor.
Bernie is from New Hampshire.
Winning New Hampshire in 2020 would not really
be a sign of anything for Bernie Sanders in
the sense that he crushed Hillary there in
the 2016 primary 60 to 38 and ultimately lost
the nomination.
I would actually go further.
If Bernie Sanders doesn't win New Hampshire
on February 11th of 2020, it's probably a
really bad sign for him in the 2020 Democratic
primary because it is a state, uh, that he
so easily won in 2016.
So this is valuable in showing us a trend
line.
It's valuable in that every primary is worth
some delegates and the more you win, the more
delegates you have towards the nomination.
We just don't want to give more value to this
one poll in one state that Bernie won in 2016
anyway than it deserves.
Now there's another interesting data point
from this poll when it comes to electability,
uh, and the matchups versus Trump.
New Hampshire voters say they'd vote for Bernie
over Trump 51 to 41, and for Biden over Trump
by an even bigger margin, 53 to 40.
This is interesting because if you look back
at 2016 in the general, Hillary Clinton won
New Hampshire, but she won by 0.37%.
If the Democratic candidate wins New Hampshire
in 2020 it doesn't matter who it is at this
point by three by four, by six, by 10 by 13
the way this poll is suggesting this would
be a massive signal in terms of the broader
election, but that being said, it's early.
Both of these margins, 51 41 and 53 40 they
include like seven to 8% undecided or third
party voters.
That is not going to be the reality by election
day, but even if all of the currently undecided
and third party voters shift to Trump by election
day, these would still be bigger wins in 2020
in New Hampshire Than Hillary Clinton had,
and it could be a pretty big signal for 2020
it's all speculative.
It's all hypothetical.
It's very early.
Everyone must vote.
No matter what you think is likely to happen
in your state.
Assume everybody should operate under the
belief which may end up not being wrong, that
every state could be 50 50 and your vote could
make the difference.
I mean literally speaking, that's not going
to be the case, but that's the attitude every
single one of us needs to have.
I'll be voting in the primary.
I'll be voting in the general, even though
I vote here in Massachusetts.
Once again, as far as New Hampshire is concerned,
this is one poll, relatively small sample
size, statistical tie.
Nothing can be assumed.
Every vote has to be cast and counted.
My question for you today relates to the quality
of the campaign that Joe Biden is running.
Does anybody in my audience think that Joe
Biden is running a good campaign?
So I'm not asking you about electability.
I'm not asking you about whether you agree
with him on the issues.
What I'm asking is, as far as campaign strategy
and visibility and logistics and debate strategy
are concerned, does anyone in my audience
believe that Joe Biden is running a strong
campaign?
I don't see it.
I want to hear from you.
Uh, make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman's for the latest urban farming, a tomato
date.
Big, big updates.
Big News there.
Check it out.
We'll take a quick break and talk
to you about the David Pakman show